we've had to fill the need for speed  because you know I'm obsessed with cars  which is about that you're on the Las  Vegas racetrack and fingers crossed hit  some cheese  [Music]  [Music]  right for a time Ferrari  my wheelhouse and what I am gonna do is  kick Zac Efron's ass  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  Zac Ephron you going down  put on the break-up to first  [Music]  [Applause]  Wow  thank you  Jason what was that time-wise we'll go  check on the computer right now  absolutely amazing  holy mackerel my dream is the bean sack  a lot cookies are seven special to him  now what was the time and the four eight  eight well goodness if you improved you  I didn't prove fifty four and nine yes  Zack not only have we gone down you're  done but get your ass back on this track  amazing the job  Jamie Oliver uh no Jamie Foxx yes domina  and I bother excuse me allow Billy  hello kicked his ass  no professor